In the world of superheroes, death is simply
a passing inconvenience.
If your favorite character dies a horrible
yet heroic death, well, it might sting for
a bit, but don't worry — they'll be back
sooner or later.
With that in mind, here's a spoiler-filled
look at some of the superheroes we lost so
far in 2017.
Rest in peace… for now.
Logan
Wolverine has been one of the most popular
superheroes in the world for decades, thanks
in large part to Hugh Jackman, who's portrayed
the character in nine movies since the year
2000.
In 2017, though, Jackman appeared in what
he swears is his final film as Wolverine,
headlining the grim Logan.
Fittingly, Jackman's final appearance as Wolverine
ended with Logan's death.
Turns out the adamantium grafted to his bones
didn't just make him indestructible — it
also was slowly poisoning him, pushing his
mutant healing factor beyond its capabilities.
So when Logan faced off against an evil clone,
his battered body finally gave up the ghost
— but not before he heroically saved a group
of mutant kids, including a totally different,
totally not evil little girl clone.
So at least some of Logan lives on somewhere,
even if it might be a little too confusing
to understand.
Professor Charles Xavier
Dedicated to the proposition that all men
are created equal, Professor Xavier has been
pursuing his dream since 1963.
And for the better part of two decades, Patrick
Stewart has been one of a pair of actors portraying
the good professor on the big screen.
Sadly, the Professor's dream turned into a
nightmare in the film Logan.
After suffering a seizure that accidentally
caused him to kill all his own students, Xavier
was put into a drugged stupor by his last
remaining pupil, Logan.
Professor X's pain finally came to an end
when Logan's evil clone killed him right in
the middle of a road trip to the woods of
North Dakota.
That seems like a fittingly convoluted way
for the original X-Man to die.
Jack Flag
First debuting back in 1994, Jack Harrison
was originally a member of a citizen's patrol
group who responded to reports submitted to
Captain America's danger hotline.
But during a fight with Mr. Hyde, he got drenched
in super chemicals and became a real deal
superpowered hero under the name Jack Flag.
After bouncing around the Marvel Universe
for two decades, even joining the Guardians
of the Galaxy at one point, Jack Flag and
his on-again-off-again partner Free Spirit
were eventually recruited by Captain America
to Join SHIELD.
Unknown to them, however, Steve had been turned
evil by the reality-warping powers of the
Cosmic Cube and was actually working for Hydra.
Jack discovered this the hard way when Steve
Rogers tossed him out of a plane.
Jack survived the fall, but was left brain
dead until Free Spirit decided to pull the
plug.
Jack, we hoist a patriotic face bandana to
your memory.
Hack
When you join a team called the Suicide Squad,
you have to know your time is limited.
The superhero known as Hack found this out
the hard way.
A tech-savvy metahuman who grew up in the
slums of Nairobi, Hack had the unique ability
to interact with computers using her mind,
allowing her to surf the web and download
information directly into her head, as well
as turn people into digital code and transport
them through the internet.
But rather than simply use her powers to binge-watch
YouTube, Hack decided to help the Suicide
Squad.
Along the way, she accidentally discovered
that the team had traitors in their midst.
Before she could reveal this shocking information,
one of those traitors, Captain Boomerang,
stabbed her to death.
Alas, poor Hack.
We hardly knew ye.
Patriot
When it comes to classic superheroes, it doesn't
get much more old school than Jeffrey Mace,
The Patriot, who first debuted way back in
1941.
Though his heyday in the comics ended long
ago, The Patriot got a second lease on life
thanks to Marvel's Agents of SHIELD, where
he appeared in season four as the spy agency's
new director.
Blessed with powers thanks to a super soldier
serum, Mace ended up entering the virtual
reality program called The Framework in order
to rescue some of his agents.
And just like in The Matrix, if you die in
the Framework, you die in reality too.
"Whoa."
While Mace performed a rescue inside the program,
Madame Hydra blew up the building he was in.
Mace was able to use his powers to save everyone
else in the building and give them time to
escape — but at the cost of his own life.
"Coulsen?" "I'm right here, hang on."
"Go."
Bucky Barnes, The Winter soldier
That used to be one basic rule when it came
to bringing back dead characters: everyone
could return except for Peter Parker's Uncle
Ben and Captain Amercia's sidekick Bucky Barnes,
who died while trying to defuse one of Baron
Zemo's flying bombs during World War II.
That rule was famously violated, though, when
Bucky returned from the dead as the Soviet
sleeper super agent, the Winter Soldier.
However, all good things must come to an end,
including Bucky's second life.
After Captain America was turned evil by the
Cosmic Cube, evil Steve Rogers teamed up with
the new Baron Zemo.
They captured Bucky, and, in a cruel twist,
re-enacted his original death by strapping
him to a replica of that same flying bomb
and blowing him sky high.
Don't worry, though, he'll probably be back.
After all, it's happened before.
"Bucky?"
"Who the hell is Bucky?"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!